who walks into a person in a wheelchair
dumb thing back I'm Abby Lee Miller and
today I'm reacting to viral memes of me
you treat theater Connecticut put it
away
I'm just trying to tell somebody a
producer probably something that was
going to happen and making sure my phone
was turned off and then Barbie gets up
and causes a big sting and yells
in the meantime it's her kid dancing so
she didn't even want your own kid I
don't need to watch that kid it's not my
kid right
[Music]
because I don't know I think I'm gonna
go to Baskin-Robbins and I'm a Baskin
Robbins fan from day one
okay
because it was just the back up and I'm
out no one's talking to me like that and
you don't touch people like when you're
in a wheelchair and people come up
behind you and they touch you it's scary
because my peripheral vision is great
but I can't see all the way behind my
chair and it scares you see me jump like
you can literally see uh we levitate out
of that chair for a split second and I'm
not putting up with that crap no they're
just right there we're gonna have to
speed up a little then I went around the
world and I went to the police station
and I filed a police report because you
have to do that as a woman in today's
society when someone harasses you or
abuses you or whatever you file for your
support
don't you think by now I would have a
deal with Baskin Robbins and when I walk
in I should get a free code boring
yawning
sloppy
lazy that's not a moment that's every
single day of my life I'm telling
somebody lazy boring yawning this is a
meme that comes in handy this is a meme
that I would use I see I'm on the verge
of figuring women out
hahaha
I'm in this old kind of Victorian house
place and I don't know who the guy is
I'm just cracking up it wasn't something
he said I think it was just his whole
look his whole vibe like people want to
fix me up with people they don't know my
type by now come on
[Music]
it's genuine it's real and it's
hilarious I even laughed along with me
laughing you know what I mean I'm
looking at myself and it made me laugh
so I think it's just somebody cracks up
when you're in church and you like get
the giggles and you just can't stop
laughing that's what it was like did you
just sit here and say that my daughter
looks miserable so maybe we should put
Kalani in her place no I never said yes
you most certainly do no I didn't dang
that she lost control she couldn't keep
her hands to herself listen I said
Brooke is your mother
it's also horrible that the state of New
York press charges against her it wasn't
me personally
they came in they assessed the situation
they press charges against her which in
turn caused me to fly to New York three
times to go to court to be there to
testify for nothing to ever happen
and when I fly to New York I don't just
go to court and turn around and go home
I have to see a Broadway show I have to
shop I have to eat I have to stay at a
hotel I spend 10 grand for nothing
Kelly was my student
she started with me as a toddler
in the preschool classes when she was
young she knows the rules she disobeys
them she is disrespectful
she is extremely disrespectful to other
people's children so when I say dingbat
I mean it I know what I'm dealing with
I just pretend it doesn't matter
I can't pretend anymore my hair looks
good there too that's the only thing I
look at Kendall's actually paying
attention and not zoned out so it must
have been important
wait what did I say I didn't see it
oh the gay culture my buddies right they
are out there and they see the hot guy
walk in and they're like
okay well that's much better than the
way I felt and that's the truth
[Music]
I have no idea what I'm talking about
but I know that I chill on a fell out of
the chair
that's funny because it's like I pulled
the chair out from underneath her okay
I'm done thank you
I don't know why I said I'm done because
I never say I'm done I say steaks are
done people are finished I'm a Problem
Solver especially when it comes to
choreography let's fix it let's figure
this out and no they want to bring the
moms in and get their opinion and blah
blah blah it's like just let's go she
deserves nothing
you deserve nothing moms always say but
my daughter deserves another chance or
my daughter deserves the solo my
daughter deserves to be in the front
that's what I was trying to tell the
child and her mother she deserves
nothing you earn it you work for it you
pay for it
let's just say the devil made me do it
that is from Snapchat I love those
filters I love them no wrinkles
I didn't see them yes you did
oh my God
when you're in a wheelchair
you are treated differently oh my God
if they tried to talk to her and she
like kind of ran them over
hi
who walks into a person in a wheelchair
dumb thing about
Gia do you know the order of the solos
Jojo
have you learned nothing
okay did you see her mother's face
she knows her mother knows that the kid
was in the wrong do not address her
until she learns to say excuse me when
two adults are speaking see my parents
were big on manners and you're a child
do not speak unless you're spoken to do
not interrupt adults that's just
inappropriate
I am too old for that crap so when JoJo
came in to the team to the group after
Abby's Ultimate Dance Competition into
Dance Moms she had to learn how to be
part of a team to be a team player and
that was all new to her she's really
smart and Savvy when it comes to social
media give that kid a computer and she
can make you a million bucks so when we
were on the bus riding and everybody was
playing with each other's hair and doing
this and doing that and here's Jojo
what's the Wi-Fi what's the Wi-Fi the
Wi-Fi went out I need another number who
has a hot spot blah blah blah that's I
was like oh my God what and she was
uploading it and editing her videos for
YouTube and I should have been doing
that with her I'd be much wealthier well
off now yes and now I want to sit back
and relax and enjoy my evening when all
of a sudden I hear this agitating
grading voice I thought it was a great
day and everything was wonderful and I'm
taking pictures with kids and that's
what I hear the voice the voice I'm
allowed to have mine
what's your opinion
I think I can read people because I had
different types of people from all walks
of life and when it comes to their kids
you know what they're going to say
before they say it you know that's why
in teaching
the kids start at 4 30 and I am tough on
them and we're warming up but we're
doing the bar their leg and their butt
they're blah blah blah every day every
day Tuesday Thursday every day right and
I mean I mean I say nasty things then
it like eight o'clock I say something
really nice like oh my God that turn was
stunning because at 8 39 they're getting
in the car to go home and I just want
the kid to remember the last thing I
said to them not what I said for three
hours previously that I was
on them I'm gonna say something really
nice and pretty at the end so they get
in the car and go
all right that's it don't forget use
your memes of me
[Music]